going greenwald is co-founder at the
intercept and joins us tonight plan
where's the diversity in general I mean
this is one of the problems I think that
allowed the media to just go so far off
the rails is that especially those two
cable networks but also even newspapers
pretty much prohibited dissent from ever
being heard so they constantly fed each
other these conspiracy theories and told
each other that they were on the right
track every time they advanced it
further and never really had to confront
anybody who questioned or challenged
them in any way I've spent the last two
years debating everyone I can find who
had different views than I had on this
whole saga because I wanted to make
certain that the things I were saying
were scrutinized and subjected to
critical rigor and that's exactly what
they avoided and that's the reason why
they went so far off the rails like I
said the first time I saw one of your in
your new show is when you had a Adam
Schiff on your set for 12 minutes and
you and he went back and forth and
debated that's what those other networks
have refused to do and that's why
they're in such a bubble where they have
no idea what's going on in the world so
I think after today the focus my focus
would shift naturally to how do you fix
this I mean you need a functioning media
even if I didn't agree with the people
in it or don't like them or don't like
who they vote for you still need like
adults covering news and keeping the
powerful you know under a closed eye how
do we fix this they're so discredited
and broken and unwilling to admit it
what do you do now with the American
media it's really interesting I mean
after the Iraq war when the media helped
the Bush administration convince the
country to go to war based on false
claims about the weapons program of
Saddam Hussein there was at least some
self-reflection some introspection some
journalistic assessment about mistakes
that were made and attempts to reform
here I don't see any of that if you
listen to the media discourse outside of
the few circles they just put collusion
and conspiracy and all of those
conspiracy theories they've spent the
last three years endorsing just flushed
it down the toilet like they don't even
exist and just seamlessly shifted to
obstruction and then and then they're
conflating them too
claim essentially that they were right
all along and that is really the
alarming thing I think that in a lot of
ways Donald Trump broke the brains of a
lot of people particularly people in the
media who believe that telling eyes
inventing conspiracy theories being
journalistically reckless it's all
justified to stop this unparalleled
menace and that's a good thing for an
activist to think and a really bad thing
for a journalist to think so you don't
sound hopeful that it can be repaired
well I mean I you know you were talking
just now about impeachment already Adam
Schiff and Steny Hoyer have both said
that they don't intend to pursue
impeachment charges they think that
tells you all you need to know about
their assessment of the political value
here they know that they've been
discredited and so I think that if
Democrats on the hill know that this
whole thing has collapsed as a hoax
hopefully the media allies of theirs
will come to that same realization and
start to have at least a little bit of
shame yeah about what they've done to
their credibility and and hopefully I'm
hopeful that that will happen though I
don't necessarily think it's inevitable
you never grow unless you're ashamed
I've never learned to anything except
through failure and shame and so I think
that's a human truth so I hope they do
click green well thank you that you were
right you have nothing to be ashamed of
thanks tiger in this case Thanks